-I feel like,
every time you're here,
we talk about you're
about to break a record,
you're breaking a record.
Now it's official --
the longest-running drama
in television history.
That's amazing.
-Crazy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Crazy, crazy.
-And the longest-running
character, as well.
You've been there
from the beginning.
Olivia's been there
It must be such a trip.
-I have a necklace to prove it
-Do you really?
-Yeah. How about that?
-Wow, "21!" There it is!
-21!
-Wow.
-And that's not my age.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you -- It is a show --
obviously, that not only
airs on NBC once a week,
but it's also on all the time.
Are you aware of this?
-I am.
I can't get away from myself
-Yeah.
Are you ever flipping around
and you see your--
Do you stop if you see
an old episode of "SVU?"
-Usually, not.
-Yeah.
-However, about a month ago,
I did and I stopped.
And it was so old, and I'm like,
"I don't remember that."
And I said, "oh, I'll just watch
and remember
what episode it was."
And I sat there,
watching and watching.
Half-hour went by,
got completely engrossed
in the show.
Didn't remember a thing.
Didn't even know it was me
[ Laughter ]
Like, "This is a good show."
But it was so sad,
because I could not remember
And then I tried to remember
and I just couldn't.
-That's -- I mean --
-That's sad.
-Yeah.
I mean, you know --
I've been doing this one now -
we've done this
for over five years.
But I wonder
when the time will come
that I will -- someone --
I will see someone
and forget that they were
a guest on the show.
-Oh.
-Do you forget guest stars ever?
-Constantly.
-Yeah.
-It's bad.
-But it's not so much
that I forget them.
Like, the other day,
I was watching "SNL."
And there was this amazing
actor, amazing host.
And I -- We know
who we're talking about.
He's so genius.
And he was so hilarious.
And I said, "That guy's good
That guy's great!
Who is that guy?"
And he's a huge star
of his own show.
-Yeah.
-And then everyone went,
"Yeah, he was on 'SVU.'"
-Yeah, David Harbour.
-That's the one!
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-And I couldn't remember.
And I was so embarrassed.
And then I went,
"Hey, I know that guy."
-Well, it was interesting,
'cause, David Harbour was here
a couple weeks ago,
right before he hosted "SNL.
And he was talking about,
before "Stranger Things,"
like, that was the sort of thing
he was in all the time.
He sort of played --
He kind of played scuzzier guy
who were getting in troubl
on "SVU."
-And that's why
I didn't recognize him.
-Yeah.
-But he made me happy on "SNL.
-And I think
that's a good reminder
to all criminals,
is that you can, at some point
turn it around and host "SNL."
-Start over.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- I want to ask
about your early work,
'cause we found, you started
wanting to be a comedian.
-Sort of.
-Yeah, but that appealed to you.
-I thought that's where
we were going with it.
-Gotcha.
-I thought that's what --
You know, I did some stuff
a lot of sitcoms.
And I thought,
"This is gonna be great."
Did a bunch, four in a row
But I didn't always have
such a great working record.
-Yeah, you did -- We found
a film that you were in
that shot in Australia?
Is that right?
-That's the one.
-Yeah.
And it was --
-It's just funny
to hear about the
longest-running character,
the longest-running TV show,
but it didn't
start out like that.
-No, this was
a very short-run character
-Well, super short.
A little too short for me.
-It was a "Power Rangers" movie.
-I was going to be the Queen
-You were the Queen
in a "Power Rangers" movie
-That was me.
-Look at that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Look at -- Look at that.
What was your --
Do you remember the Queen's --
-It was -- I think her nam
was Dulcia or Dulcinea.
-Uh-huh.
-But I was so excited
because I was going to Australia
to play this Queen.
-Yeah.
-I get there,
hair, makeup, prosthetic pieces,
walking around like that,
feeling pretty good.
-Yeah.
-And it was shooting
in Australia.
And then I was there
for November...
-Uh-huh.
-And then December.
And then we were getting
close to Christmas.
And they had me on hold a lot.
And finally,
around December 21st,
I said, "Hey, guys,
this is great,
but you kept me on hold
too long.
I got to go. It's Christmas.
-Yeah.
-"I think that's only fair."
-Yeah, yeah.
-So I go home.
I fly home in December.
January 3rd, I call them.
I'm like, "Okay, I'm ready."
And they're like,
"Sweetie, you're good.
Don't worry about it."
-Really?
-Yes, and they fired me.
-Wow!
-Yep.
-'Cause you left the movie
-Because I wanted to
go home for Christmas
and be with my family.
-Yeah.
They -- Did you learn
a valuable lesson
about being an actor?
-Yes.
I watch my P's and Q's
on "SVU" now.
And when they say,
"We need you,"
I said, "I'm there,
and I'm ready."
[ Laughter ]
So far, so good.
-Did they recast you,
or did they --
-They did.
-Wow.
-Yes, they did.
-So, this is like --
I mean, this very hard to find
what we found.
I mean, this, like,
barely exists anywhere.
-Nobody knows this.
-Yeah.
-Just us.
[ Laughter ]
-One thing we also
figured out is --
-I'm going to make wallpaper
by the way, of that.
-Yeah.
-Is that bad?
-No, no. You should.
This is a good one, too.
There was one more
I didn't show.
This is you in all your
splendor, Queen Dulcinea.
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, it's very --
It's very Wonder Woman-y.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-These are the early beginning
of all my love
for these super --
-Yeah, the power --
women of power.
-Women of power.